Yo, what up.
My name is Christina Elmore,
and I play Condola.
I'm Jay Ellis, and I've been
playing Lawrence for 4 seasons.
-That's right!
-It's been amazing.
♪ (MELLOW MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
Okay, I feel like men
are often called like...
...whatever,
because they can't either
forgive or they can't move on
or they can't have friendships
with their exes, right?
And I feel like Lawrence
has that with Issa...
Yes, of course,
it's a little bit awkward
that his friend Issa
is also friends and working with
-his girlfriend Condola.
-Yeah, for sure.
I feel like...
She like drives the--
She makes it the thing.
Lawrence doesn't make it
the thing.
You think Condola makes it
the thing?
Yeah.
So, when Lawrence comes
into that kitchen,
and he says to Condola,
"I feel like...
Lawrence hasn't really gotten
over his past relationships--
Or at least, it seems that way
to Condola.
Yeah but Condola
hasn't really gotten over
her past relationship either.
But there's no evidence of that.
Condola won't let herself
ever get married again
because she was married.
But there's
the present-day issue at hand
that we have not reconciled.
Yes, Issa-- Issa is an issue.
Issa is a...
I don't know if even
the maturest of the mature
can handle working with,
becoming friends with a woman...
-It's a lot. It's a lot.
-...who dated your boyfriend
for five years?!
Y'all talking about him.
Telling you
all the little things he does,
and you laugh at them because
you're like,
"Oh, I've seen him do that too."
And y'all are still having
inside jokes.
And ha-ha's that I can't get in.
Well, I guess we just gotta wait
and see what happens.
'Cause they don't tell us
nothing, y'all.
-They don't. We don't know.
-We don't know.
We just show up and read.
-(CHUCKLES)
-They don't tell us nothing.
♪ (MUSIC CONCLUDES) ♪